OK fantastic
um thank you
for being here um.
I'd like you to imagine something with me
for a minute.
Picture yourself responsible
for securing the digital experiences
of 3.5 billion
people.
That's nearly half the world's
population. Logging in every
single day, sharing memories,
connecting with loved ones,
and building communities across 150
countries,
each with their own regulatory
requirements,
compliance standards,
and security expectations.
Now here's the thing.
That isn't a hypothetical scenario.
That's a that's a Wednesday
afternoon at Meta.
I'm Robin Rodriguez, a solutions architect
at AWS,
and I'm thrilled to be here at Reinvent
with you all today.
Um, on stage today we've got
myself and some incredible colleagues
Peter Neuhausen, a senior engineering
manager at Meta.
And Syed Sharif, a
security solutions architect at AWS,
uh, Syed and I have the privilege
of working alongside Mehta's team
to help deliver secure
experiences that support billions
of users,
and the scale of the challenges
that these teams tackle is
truly remarkable.
So
today's session is about what
we call
fortifying the cloud,
but it's really a lot more than that.
It's about how one of the world's largest
technology companies
has reimagined security
for the cloud era.
It's about the hard lessons
learned.
The innovative solutions discovered
and the practical wisdom that
can benefit
organizations of any size,
uh, you know, whether you're managing thousands
of workloads on AWS
or just beginning your cloud journey.
I think these principles that we're gonna share
today can transform how
you think
about
your security.
Um, so over the next hour we're gonna
talk about sort of this AWS
cloud security playbook, you
know, what are some of these key principles
for fortifying your identities,
your networks, and your resources
in AWS,
uh. And the unique challenges
that Meta's faced with their
hyper scale infrastructure and how
they've evolved
to a hybrid cloud,
you know, uh, Peter's gonna share,
you know, some of how Meta's implemented
the security controls across those
identity network
and resource domains
as well as these
real world lessons learned.
And a deep dive into how
they secure AI clusters
at massive scale
and also what's next in this
evolution of security,
uh, so I'm gonna have Syed
join us up on stage and walk us through
the AWS cloud
security playbook.
Thank you, Robin.
Let's start with a playbook for AWS cloud security,
and what does that look like?
Uh,
I have the unique privilege of being a
security specialist at AWS for
more than 6+ years now
working with some of our largest customers,
and based on our collective understanding
of security of scale we found some of these
key characteristics that apply to
all customers when they're doing cloud
security. Security
skill is defined, especially
for hyper scales like Meta, is
the convergence of ephemeral workloads.
Distributed systems
and Automation,
it's absolutely necessary at
that scale when you're trying to secure.
Edward Demming, the father of quality management,
once said, you cannot inspect your way to
quality. It has
to be embedded in the process.
Similarly,
security at scale has to be embedded in the
process all the way from desi uh
the design phase
built into dep uh the phase.
And embedded in the deployment space
and operationalized in runtime.
Security, when we say federated, what we
mean by that is security is no longer
a gatekeeper.
Or somebody who's giving a yes or no answer,
it's rather woven into the fabric
of your cloud deployments.
The the objective shift
from preventing change
to making sure
change occurs within the established
safety parameters.
Resiliency and cloud secure cloud
security is not merely the ability to prevent
bad days.
We all understand bad days happen.
The idea is how well can you withstand
and recover from such events.
The idea is to be anti-fragile. If
you've read Nicholas Tale's book,
the idea is, so what does that look like
instead of having
a
firewall that breaks under a DDoS
attack and fails open.
You have automated rules
that add the
bad IPs to your
web application firewall
and then create honey pots
so that you can actually withstand that attack
and recover from it.
When operating at scale, a thing
that we see it very often is
companies have a virtuous loop
that is created by
learning from past events,
right? We, we all agree that bad
days are going to happen,
right? And it can be Thursday morning,
but this can only be possible
when. There is an iterative
process and teams can create controls
from yesterday's event
for tomorrow's protection.
But this really really relies
on a culture that is blame-free.
Uh, incident analysis that focuses
on the technology
and timeline of the attacks
and not the people
or human error.
Thus transforming every incident
into a
Valuable learning asset for the
whole team. As
we now talk about
this. Security
at scale, let's look at some of the primary domains.
The first one, and one of the most important ones is
the identity one.
Right, and there are some key things we want to highlight here.
Uh, Uh, on the IDPSSO
one, sorry, it was somebody was trying to take a
picture. Uh,
the first one is using
an identity provider
and a single sign-on mechanism
that allows your human users.
To access
AWS
applications and accounts within AWS,
right? Um,
again, I wanna highlight
that when you're using Identity Center
it can be used for accessing AWS
applications or.
Uh, uh,
accessing AWSS accounts,
you can choose which feature you want to use or
both. Let's
look at some of the common policies when you're trying
to do security at scale, especially in a federated
manner, automated manner,
right? When you, uh,
what you do is when you're federating, you block the
bad at the Oregon level, right,
for the whole enterprise,
but then you leverage your org structure
to apply policies at the OU
and the account level
in alignment with the security requirements
of the workloads running there.
For example,
you can apply an org level SCP
that prevents
anybody in your organization from
modifying your cloud trail.
Right, or you can apply
an RCP
that prevents a certain type of
encryption being used in on your
S3 bucket that is congruous with
customers using um
for in ransomware attacks, for example.
A key things to highlight here,
um, there is also these management policies,
and one of them is declarative policies,
right? It, uh, these are
you can use them to basically
prevent noncompliant actions. For
example, you can block
public internet access to your whole VPC.
And also create helpful
error messages
for your end users.
Now when you're using
AWS at scale.
You probably are not enabling every service
in your production accounts. You're using the services that
you want
now. How do you effectively manage
service approval at scale while
maintaining your security
and enabling developer innovation? Your
developers are looking to try the latest service,
right? I'm sure some of you are excited about
trying out the new security agent and other
amazing products we've launched
yesterday. So
what you do is by implementing a tiered
approach. You create sandbox
environments where developers get the freedom
to experiment
in isolated environments from the
rest of your workloads,
and a common pattern we see is a 30 day
period for the sandbox account after which
it is gone,
but also ensuring
that sandbox environment has some
baseline security controls built
into it like allowing certain
types of data to come in and keeping data in
also allowing to like hey who has access
in there and not,
um. And then usage metrics
that you're collecting in that sandbox environment
because guess what somebody's gonna experiment
they're gonna find oh this works
let's move it to the next stage
and at that point instead of
creating the whole workload somewhere else you
might have to make a choice
to then migrate that account over into
your. Or
main workload and production accounts.
So how do you then use metrics to make that
transition easier?
So the whole idea is to use
automated guard rails replacing your
manual controls
so that you can
scale securely.
Let's talk about some of the network domain features
that come in.
One of the most is zero trust access, right?
This is to enable that your actors,
whether they're humans,
machines, or devices,
can access your resources,
uh, that they, uh, they, they should
be using,
uh. In
in a manner that does not depend on
the proximity,
rather it leverages identity and
other security features to make that.
Authorization.
So, uh, AWS
provides you,
uh, these type of, uh, these zero trust mechanisms
across the stack all the way from the edge to the cloud
APIs.
Uh, you can, uh, so you can use the
shared authorization context
and consistent authorization evaluation
across and then
also collecting telemetry all
through the phases so you can then monitor your
access pervasively.
Now obviously you're gonna have to inspect your traffic
as it goes through.
We've seen three common patterns come up very
frequently and how customers at
scale do them. The first one
is the outbound, right? You wanna
keep the safe things in and not let
them go out.
So this is about how do you keep
a connection from your resources
going out to the untrusted, um,
connection or destination.
And then some of the potential risks you're mitigating
with this kind of using a network firewall,
for example,
to limit this is um
um sensitive data being exfiltrated
or command and control type of type
of activity and such.
The colliery is the ingress pattern
right where you have an untrusted destination
sending traffic
to your internal resources.
Similarly here you can use
the same mechanisms to mitigate threats
like SQL injections, vulnerability exploits,
and such.
And then
when you're operating at scale you're gonna have
trust boundaries that are
different across your org, right? We talked about
sandbox versus not,
right? So similarly you're gonna
have your east west inspection.
This can be VPCs within the region
or VPCs across uh
uh a different region, and you
are going to inspect that traffic that's using the same mechanisms
and you'll see more
in the later slides.
One more thing I wanted to highlight is
at scale some customers use identity aware
service authorization
so we talked about how humans use this
is an example of how services use
we have a service that uh we provide that is
called um.
Lattice
what Lattice allows you to do is
create a lattice network for
your applications running in say your
VPC connecting to a different application
running in a different VPC
and right now these applications do
not have any access,
but using lattice you can create
service definitions, target groups,
and action policies,
rules that allow you
to then make this access possible
but behind the scenes it's leveraging.
Other constructs like AWSIM
to make this
connection possible.
Now let's talk about data governance,
especially when it talks about resources, right?
The foundation of this is understanding your data
landscape.
Your security here starts with data classification
and protection measures
that match the data sensitivity,
right? You cannot protect everything the same way.
You have to choose to apply your security resources
to your most valuable,
um, assets. One of my
mentors in my early in my security career
told me do not put steel locks on plywood
doors.
And that has never left me, so some of the
critical decisions here
are. Regions where
your data can live
because of some compliance reasons could be
or encryption requirements and backup
requirements. Now
one of the key things that comes up here that we've seen
customers
uh do at scale very successfully
is managing your AWS KMS keys,
right? When you're operating at scale,
you're gonna have a lot of KMS keys.
AWS KMS keys are protected
by PIPS 143 level 3 hardware
security modules.
I know a lot of words,
but, uh, what I'm trying to say is, but it
gives you a lot of options. It gives you a lot of
options in terms of how and where you create the keys,
but also the way the key material comes from.
So some of the best practices we see is like a
lot of times central security teams
love to keep the keys in their control.
Well, a challenge we commonly come across
with that pattern is
now you're basically all the KMS
level coders are applying at that account
that you have in your central management account for
security. Rather,
you take the keys and move them closer, so
data has gravity. Similarly, it's, it's
pulling the encryption key with it.
But that doesn't mean your central team
does not have control over it.
You still get the same governance by
using SCPs and RCPs
that we talked about earlier to
ensure that these keys are protected appropriately,
but that now one,
the keys closer to the data itself and
the quotas on key key usage
especially
are from that account with the keys being
used. Uh,
and similarly when you're doing bringing your own
key material,
uh, KMS keys, uh, KMS
allows you to do that, but it's
consideration there you have to make is what
are the performance and operational overhead
that I'm taking on for doing this.
I understand there are always very good
compliance reasons and regulatory reasons to do that,
but understanding where they apply and then using
it appropriately versus using it in blanket
across your org.
Now the the thing that we wanna talk about is
how organizations implement defense in depth
using a validation for infrastructure as
code when you're doing we talked about automation,
you know, you're gonna have all your infrastructure defined as code
hopefully you're not clicking in the console,
uh, and
so what it needs to happen infrastructure validation
needs to happen in multiple layers from the development
stage in your IDs or your CICD pipelines
all the way down through deployment.
So what does that look like? Let's look at an example. So
you have a terraform core calling your,
uh, a telephone, a template being created
using the AWSCC provider.
This one called the cloud control API,
which then if you have come across cloud formation
hooks, which is a manner of basically intercepting
these in the target environment and then checking
them for compliance with the rules applied in that
target environment.
So that would then take those cloud cloud
formation hooks they could evaluate it. So
in this scenario, say if you are creating a 3 bucket
right now you created a rule in
this target environment,
not. For your whole org
which is scanning every template,
but in the target environment where it says, well, here
I actually want a very specific, say
you're doing,
uh, a federal type of
project and then you need dual layer encryption
so you can create a rule that says all my
three buckets here need to have dual layer encryption
and that hook will evaluate that using
that. So then
based on the past fail you can have a helpful
message that then goes back
to the developer.
Immutable infrastructure
means treating infrastructure as code
that never changes after deployment.
Basically no in-place updates.
No infrastructure has worsened.
And changes trigger new deployments.
This eliminates unauthorized modifications,
click ops.
Ensures consistent security posture,
provides clear audit trails,
and enables rapid security responses.
The idea is when you're doing cloud
security scale, immutability, immutability
transforms your infrastructure as a potential
vulnerability.
To a reliable security boundary.
Now let's talk about data parameters where
a lot of these things come together and something
that we see a lot of customers at scale implement
to reach their security objectives.
Uh,
so what is it
before you build that firm boundary that
I just put on the slide,
you need to define what that means for your
organization, right?
What are the approved data patterns?
And What is that do
you trust something you own.
Something that AWS owns on your behalf
or something a third trusted third party owns
for you. So
in this case you have trusted identities,
uh, resources,
and networks.
So let's look at some of the key objectives for data
perimeter. As you
can see here,
these are the key objectives about who can access
what from where
defined by the different parameters of identity,
network, and resource.
The identity perimeter primarily mitigates
uh unauthorized access by identities
external to your organization.
The resource perimeter uh
um mitigates unintended data movement
to resources outside of your organization
and the network perimeter mitigates
credential use outside of
your uh corporate environment so for example.
Now let's quickly look at how this is all worked
together, right?
So, hey, I have my trusted identity
going to my trusted resource.
Well, I'm fine, that's everything goes through,
but hey, now I have untrusted identities
like I work for a company, but I
brought my own credentials from my AWS
environment, personal envi environment, and I try to
use it.
Guess what? The identity perimeter is gonna block
that. What about
I go home using my company
credentials and try to access those resources.
My network parameter blocks out.
And then I have my, I use my personal
credentials trying to get to the trusted resource
it blocks by the identity perimeter again.
Now, say I'm working
uh in my corporate environment
and I'm trying to go
to my own personality bucket, an exfiltration
type of scenario.
How do these parameters work?
Well, if it is a, if you're trying to use your corporate,
uh, uh, credentials and try to go to
this non-corporate resources, the resource parameter
will block it.
Similarly, if you're trying to use your personal credentials, the
identity perimeter,
uh, but say you're coming from outside network
and then trying to go to these resources, the network perimeter
will block it. In
this table
you can see where the different data parameters
are applied
and the different
appropriate
policies that are used.
And the primary IM features
that are used for achieving the objectives
of that perimeter.
Uh, I hope this was, uh, I know this was a
lot of information,
and, uh,
but I, I, I wanted to set you up with like
some of the key characteristics we see of enterprise
security at scale.
Please welcome at this point Meta from Peter
from Meta to come and talk about how
they have built their cloud security at scale.
Thank you. Great,
thank you, Syed.
So today I would like to talk about the uh
scale challenge
with Meta's cloud security reality.
I'm pretty sure you've all thought
about building for scale,
but what does that mean?
You know, being able to handle traffic
on New Year's Day, on Christmas Eve,
when everyone wants to connect all at the same
time to your service.
Today we're going to talk about building at meta-scale.
And as you can imagine, operating at this
scale comes with many challenges.
So we'll start by digging into some of the
interesting and unexpected things
that happen with planet scale social media.
Before we go deep into Mehta's cloud infrastructure,
I want to take a moment to share Mehta's mission,
which is to build the future of human connection
and the technology that makes it possible.
We've been a social technology company since
day one,
and our technology stack reflects this in
many ways.
Compared to much of the industry, we're contrarian,
because the social connection tech
problems we're trying to solve,
Uh, our innovations
give people new ways to connect,
and we're committed to keep
everyone safe,
make a positive impact on the world.
With 3.5 billion daily active
users,
the world relies on meta to connect
and communicate.
We have a truly global user base.
And can't build with any certainty
about who is connecting with whom.
We were born a tech company and maintain
an incredibly strong, bottoms up
engineering culture.
I don't really need to say that, we
like to lead the development of emerging
technologies
such as mixed reality and open source
AI. Today I'm
happy to share some
of the exciting work we're doing in expanding our
infrastructure
into AWS.
Supporting 3.5 billion
daily active users,
with many generating content requires
infrastructure at hyper scale.
Social media workloads typically exhibit
higher transaction rates than most
large scale internet sites and
systems.
To me that's to be expected.
With social media, the cost per transaction,
such as liking a post or watching a video,
Doesn't require movement of physical
goods or the exchange of money.
So the real world transaction cost is very low.
We're not limited by the number of widgets in our
e-commerce warehouse.
We're not limited by the number of planes
or seats or airport capacity.
This means we see orders of magnitude
higher transaction rates than most
other global distributed computing platforms.
Cap theorem is definitely in play here,
and eventual consistency is something we think about
a lot.
Without the constraints of the physical world,
our global user base loves connecting
in unexpected ways.
Our systems support diverse security,
data and privacy compliance requirements.
We've made huge investments in developing a privacy
aware infrastructure.
It builds on each request's context
and applies privacy policies in real time.
This enables teams to programmatically define
the who, what,
when and where their service should
be called and data should flow.
Meta deals with these unique requirements
by building a globally consistent graph database.
There are not many workloads that need this kind
of infrastructure, and you can find research
papers about how we did this if you
look up the tower system.
Meta is building innovative experiences
that are at the forefront of reimagining
the way we interact in community.
Building systems that power
experiences like mixed reality and
open source foundational models
require new approaches
to scalability and the secure handling of
data.
We're working on solving these challenges at the infrastructure
level. Meta's
strong engineering culture means we continue
to focus
on building highly scalable, hyperscale
infrastructure.
We're already a hyper-scaler,
and we continue investing in our own data centers,
backbone cables, and edge connectivity.
It's these kind of investments that let us do
things like launching the Threads app to
100 million users in the first week.
Without this kind of infrastructure, it
wouldn't be possible.
But even that's not enough
for AI.
So we're doing hybrid cloud.
And on a big scale.
We terminate direct connect fiber in our own
premises.
And we already have a security infrastructure
available.
This gives us confidence to push further into
the cloud.
And a lot of the security assumptions
we've already made
help us work
and keep our infrastructure secure
across multiple clouds.
Meta has been the forefront of AI
application research for many years.
It started with ranking content on
the news feed and following Instagram reels.
Uh,
we, uh, we then doubled down on GPU
infrastructure buildouts.
In 2022, that was the year
of the large language models,
with Meta entering the race with our LA
system. Successive
llama versions were trained on our own infrastructure,
and as we've seen in the media, Mark has
launched
our Super intelligence Labs initiative.
We're in the process of building out our
class leading Prometheus
1 gigawatt
and Hyperion 5 gigawatt
superclusters.
Even with all these efforts, we have AI
research workloads
that still need more capacity
and feature job sizes that
are well suited to GPU capacity in the cloud.
These jobs don't need the hyperscale contiguous
clusters
we are building in our own data centers.
In this talk, we'll go deeper
on what makes Metas cloud
deployments unique and how we set up our
AWS architecture
to securely scale.
A bit of background on meta now.
Most meta software engineering teams
develop systems
that run in our existing hyperscale container
environments.
These are well suited to the small web
requests that we see from the family of apps.
Meta does run significant compute workloads
in the cloud as well.
The Cloud Foundation team is Mehta's team
of cloud experts
who are responsible
for low level infrastructure such as
transit accounts,
direct connect links,
Um, and building systems that enable
efficient enforcement
of cloud security standards.
We help facilitate cloud usage across the
business
and we've built an infrastructure fabric layer
that provides identity, authentication,
public key infrastructure,
metrics, monitoring, and a host of other
support services.
Our team accelerates efficient and conformant
use of the cloud
resources. We build, we
provide building blocks such as prepackaged
AMI's,
Kubernetes images,
uh, and a build pipeline.
This helps our software feature teams to automatically
support our privacy aware infrastructure
constructs and stay secure and
compliant while moving
quickly. As
we've expanded beyond our own data centers,
the network edge
no longer provides a strong data boundary.
And we increasingly rely on a sophisticated
identity system
to grant least privileged access to user
and service roles.
We have a centralized IAM system.
That is integrated across all of our internal
systems.
We use role-based access control,
for granting only a minimal set
of capabilities required to
execute the workload
or administrative task.
We use machine attestation
to ensure the integrity of the host,
and as input to generate short-lived
role specific credentials.
Short-lived credentials reduce the blast radius
of lost
or stale credentials and reduce
the need for complex revocation,
And untimely renewal.
We stream cloud trail and other AWS
logs into Metas production infrastructure
and scan for anomalies in real time.
A strong identity and public key infrastructure
gives us the confidence to extend our network
into the cloud and support these workloads
on demand.
Auth-D is our credential vending service.
It abstracts away the different credential
and token retrieval mechanisms
across different clouds.
When a request
comes in from a Metaprod user or system,
Authteer receives a service call with a cloud
account ID,
a role and some associated identities.
At the auth checking step,
we validate that the requested
resources exist
in the cloud account.
And check if the request is allowed by policies
stored in our internal AM system.
If the checks fail, we return an author
permissions error.
If the request is approved,
we retrieve the credentials from the cloud service
provider.
This is a step where we translate
between internal security constructs and
different types of credentials you need in
the cloud.
In the case of AWS, this might
be, might take the form of STS
tokens,
uh Kubernetes tokens,
or even SSH certificates.
In many cases we generate a set of credentials
that are only used for that specific request.
This gives us full end to end traceability
of each user session or job creation,
which is crucial for maintaining our data
lineage.
I'll cover data controls
and share an example of how
our privacy aware architecture maintains
context as data is processed.
If assembling the credential package fails,
we return a service error to the user.
We have a standardized error categories,
um,
Of permissions, service, or cloud errors,
allowing exceptions to be handled correctly
and if necessary,
routed
uh to the correct service teams.
Once the user has the correct credential package,
they can assume the temporary role with
the permissions needed to access their cloud
resources.
The user then calls assume role with SAML
and starts their SSH session or
executes their job.
Cloud Foundation maintains building blocks
to refresh credentials as required.
This setup works well for us
because we have a highly technical teams
using the cloud, and this extra layer of
complexity
pays off in the time saved in
maintaining static credentials and
doing on-demand rotation.
Meta has a fairly unique IPV6
only infrastructure.
And we, and what we save on
NAT and IP address space exhaustion calculations,
we spend on BGP infrastructure.
That optimizes routing tables and
makes sure that they're not
too big for the routers to support.
We do still have some networking controls at
scale,
and we do our best to enforce a one workload
per cloud account policy.
This automatically gives us VPC isolation
between workloads and cloud Foundation maintains
transit and common service VPCs
in separate accounts.
We pay a lot of attention to strict
internet ingress and egress controls,
which helps immensely with maintaining data lineage
for our privacy aware infrastructure.
We grant east-west connectivity between
VPC's quite liberally,
um,
and this helps us enforce the one workload per
account rule by not um,
Restricting those connections too seriously.
As you'll see coming up, even with IPV6
everywhere,
we still have quite a lot of subnet complexity.
Meta uses IPV6 everywhere.
It starts with multiple public slash 32
rangers.
There's a lot of addresses, and I won't try
to make sense of the number of zeros today,
but it's more IP addresses than grains of sand
on Earth.
We don't need to worry about running out.
With this many addresses, we can allocate a slash
62 per host,
and we even allocate one IP per Tupperware
task.
This is our equivalent of a Kubernetes task.
So this means anything running on the
meta infrastructure can route to any
device or other task,
and we have no more IP address conflicts
or NAT running in the network.
The trade-off here is a huge BGP infrastructure
where we manage routing tables and make sure we
don't exceed the capability of the physical
routers.
This is even more of a problem
with some of the cloud providers who limit the number of static
routes we can use per account or
per VPC.
However, on the whole,
being able to extend our layer 3 network
all the way through to a cloud VPC
is really nice.
We can then let network engineering manage
direct connect links
and decide whether traffic is routed over
direct connect, VPN
or over the internet into our cloud infrastructure.
One last thing before we get to the interesting stuff,
I have a couple of infrastructure assumptions to go
over. Cloud Foundation
provides something of a managed experience to cloud
consumer teams within Meta.
Working with our security teams, we've set up
some fairly strict rules about how they're
allowed to use the cloud.
Some of these come from protecting our digital assets
and others from hard lessons learned when scaling
up the number of people
maintaining specific accounts.
We only allow our cloud consumers to view
their accounts from the console.
We're pretty strict about enforcing the use of infrastructure
as code.
Through terraform modules and integration
we built into Meta's main CICD
system. Terraform
code allows the same peer review
processes
as all other code going into our mono repository.
We're making progress towards real continuous
deployment
of terraform code,
and several of our large scale systems
are called terraform apply every 2 hours.
We use service gating on production accounts
to ensure we've got internal support
for new or complex AWS services
before, before letting our customers go
wild. When teams
just need to experiment, we offer short-lived
sandbox accounts.
Um,
which we automatically isolate at
the two week mark.
We also offer Meta Instance,
which is a nicely prepackaged AMI
that carries all the software
necessary to connect back into meta-services,
providing things like identity, logging,
metrics, and service registration
right out of the box for free.
Robust encryption controls are a key
factor in building our confidence in moving workloads
to the cloud.
I won't go into too much detail here, but
it's important to know that these exist within our infrastructure
and are critical in enabling rapid build-out
of our cloud capacity.
Our internal public key infrastructure
includes multiple route CAs
and a cloud specific CA
so we can track where certificates are used,
and prevent them from passing between infrastructure,
um, Infrastructure boundaries.
We use EC2 instance attestation
to generate X509 machine certificates
that allow us to trust the hardware and
operating system environments.
By regularly regenerating these certificates,
we can tell if anything changed on the hardware
or firmware.
We secure all connections with mutual TLS
ensuring both ends of the connection are verified
and helping to mitigate men in the middle attacks.
Our direct connect links are encrypted using Macsec
at layer 2.
With the building blocks covered, let's dive into our
case study.
Uh
Of building a secure AI cluster
on AWS.
There are several unique challenges with AI
clusters due to the GPU scarcity
and the large volumes of data
transfer
needed to run some of these mega-scale clusters.
We also don't need the same level of resiliency
and availability
that come from service serving
online production traffic.
It's a bit of an all or nothing situation here.
Is there any point in having a data store
available when the GPUs that are paired with
it have gone offline?
I don't think so.
We don't really get to dictate which AZ
the GPUs are delivered in due
to physical space and power constraints.
So we've set up our infrastructure for rapid
deployment of AI clusters and
we don't allow AI training jobs
to span multiple clusters.
Researchers also have unique needs.
They often work via an interactive session.
Uh, on the same host as the physical hardware.
They often schedule packs of slurm jobs
across large blocks of GPU capacity.
They collaborate directly with other researchers
and frequently exchange code via GitHub,
um, GitHub.
They may need to pull in datasets from the public
internet and in short, they need
easy access to the internet while safeguarding
against leaking weights and biases
or finished models.
Now I'll go into more detail about how we build
out this secure infrastructure.
We'll start this picture with the meta production
data centers.
Reduced to 2 here for simplicity,
and because my slide just isn't quite big
enough. You'll
hear more about that theme quite a bit as we go
into the details here.
There are quite, uh, these are quite monumental by
themselves.
You can consider these analogous to AWS
regions,
um, with multiple physical data centers
within those two purple boxes.
We terminate our own fiber in the data centers
and there's no co-location facilities
in this left side of the diagram.
Then we have our shiny new GPU hosts
delivered by Amazon as reserved instances
in a particular availability zone.
The location of the GPUs and accompanying
storage hosts dictates which AZ
we build out the rest of the infrastructure.
When the hosts land, our automated tooling
sets up the EKS HPC cluster
control plane and validates the GPU pods and
login pods
used by the AI researchers.
The GPU hosts are not directly on the
internet, rather we pair this VPC
with a management VPC.
This hosts internet connectivity bits,
like routers,
firewalls.
Uh, a route 53.
Uh, private hosted zone,
bastions and proxies,
allowing access
to other parts of the infrastructure and management
services for the GPU cluster.
You might have seen this architecture at
our previous reinforced talks
with a new bit today which is the storage
VPC.
GPUs might be the brains of AI,
but the storage is the heart and the circulatory
system. The
the latest GPUs demand very high
bandwidth and low latency data
access to maintain high utilization.
This means this is no mean feat in a general
purpose public cloud
without access to the specialty hardware, storage
and networking tricks that we get to
do within our own data centers.
This is especially critical when running
clusters of 10,000 or more GPUs,
uh, on many petabytes of data
spread across smallish files.
We've had a lot of challenges with the file system metadata
performance. Such
as just listing the contents of directories,
creating a separate storage VPC
and dedicating a team of engineers
to the space,
we've been able to test,
benchmark,
and tune many different flavors of
S3,
S3 Express one zone,
FSX,
Luster and Open ZFS offerings,
and running our own instances of hammer space.
We're doing all kinds of experimentation in this
space, including on top of bare
metal instances.
VPC peering comes to the rescue here.
To connect
The GPU VPC to the storage
VPC.
Um,
And we also stored checkpoints, weights
and biases
in the specialized storage systems running
in the storage VPC.
To keep everything secure, we use S3
bucket policies to block unauthorized
access inside of the storage VPC.
Now we layer in Direct Connect
from Meta's production data center.
To the storage VPC.
This is where the heavy lifting happens,
super high redundant bandwidth is in place,
with lags and diffs and multiple circuits
to reduce
the impact of individual fiber cuts
or device and rack interruptions.
These links
are where we do bulk data transfers
of the training data sets into
and out of the cloud environment.
Those GPUs are hungry beasts,
so a lot of work goes into optimizing
the data storage layers and connectivity
to try to keep this, this side of things efficient.
The last piece of the high-level view is DNS.
Remember we have IPV6 everywhere,
so there's a route 3,
there, so there is a route 53
private hosted zone in the storage
VPC
providing DNS resolution
for everything that's accessible over these direct
connect links.
With this setup,
we can decide when research and login traffic,
for example,
runs via the internet
or via the Direct Connect.
AI research workloads
often require some degree of internet connectivity.
Incoming traffic
is typically in the form of researcher SSH
logins,
service account connections, and engineers
connecting to review and optimize cluster
performance. To support this,
we have a sophisticated setup
using AWS network firewalls,
network load balancers, and NAT gateways.
On the internet ingress side, we do traffic
inspection
to prevent intrusions
and unauthorized connectivity.
The AWS network firewall lets
us cover all kinds of application traffic in
one place.
Even if the traffic is encrypted, it
can apply some controls
beyond just
the network and transport layers.
We use server name indication, extension,
and uh an enforced TLS versioning
and fingerprinting
at these NLBs.
Uh, we also use support for
AWS managed threat signatures,
which, uh, helps us to detect threats and
block attack patterns of known vulnerabilities
without having to write and maintain individual rules.
Our internet gateway setup
is, uh, is set up to only allow
ingress traffic to the AWS network
firewall
in the ingress subnet
with access restricted via routing tables.
We, we write, uh, we use
standard, industry standard,
uh, tooling
to write surikara rules for our IP
filtering
and have hundreds of entries
for meta cider blocks.
Because we have so much control over where we
allocate IPV6 siders,
we can reasonably allow incoming traffic,
uh, to be allow listed
based on the source IP.
So the connectivity gets all the way
through to our GPU VPC.
On the egress side of things, Meta again
deploys AWS network firewall
endpoints
in their own subnet with access
restricted via routing tables.
We filter HTTP and HTTPS
traffic based on domain name and
we configure domain filtering using an
an an allow listing approach.
We configure security groups
very coarsely with generally none,
metaperd siders or totally open.
VPC routing is set up to only
allow egress traffic via the egress
subnet
and domain
allow listing happens in the AWS
network firewall.
We have a self-service system for allowing
researchers
to allocate to to allow
this domains
for their cluster depending on
researcher, partner, or vendor needs.
So egress traffic follows the path of the pink
errors.
Egress inspection
protects against unauthorized outbound
traffic and can provide a
detection vector for malware communication
patterns.
To sum up, the internet connectivity part
of this,
using AWS network firewall
allows me to scale in a way security
groups don't.
Especially solving their cider
rule limitations.
Network firewall's ability to support 1
million ciders allows us to get granular
with Meta's IP space,
even when it blows out the cider blocks
from approximately 30 to more
like 200 or 2000.
Standard Surikara rules integrate
well with our internal firewall management
tooling.
Domain filtering allows me
to go beyond IP rules to domain allow
lists and blocklists.
AWS has some great white papers
on approaching centralized ingress and egress
filtering,
and we've used this to scale our solution
to what we have today.
As we move beyond infrastructure into the
application layer,
we integrate with Meta's data privacy
controls.
This is a much harder space
because a policy decision
requires an understanding of the
type and meaning of data
and the request context
before deciding if a request should be allowed
or blocked.
For example,
different privacy policies may be applied
depending on which of Mehta's family of apps
is being used for the request.
Mehta's privacy aware architecture
is a sophisticated system
that automatically applies, applies privacy
policies whenever applications
process data.
I'm only going to touch on a few aspects
of PAI today
and you can find out more on Mehta's engineering
blog. PAI
includes a central unified metadata
store
with table where table schemas and data
understanding signal annotations are stored.
Signal collection systems are responsible
for identifying the semantic type
and shape of the data
found in columns and verifying that it
matches the schema and the intended purpose.
These annotations are used to enforce
policies and establish lineage,
allowing the full life cycle of the data to be
understood and factored into
policy decisions.
I'll quickly run through the classic banana
data example from the engineering blog.
So, let's say Alice is a user
of a metasystem
and has stored some data about a
hand of bananas.
Right, she might own this hand of bananas, she's
bought it from a store.
These diagrams show how that data could
be represented
across a number of different data warehouse
contexts.
We might find
a table context
in the top left there.
Uh,
Where the data on individual bananas is
stored,
including their color,
country and flavor,
we might consider this as the as
the online or base representation
of the data.
As we process this into a data
warehouse,
we might be interested in a column
representation,
where instances of Sundays
have portions of Alice's banana
data in them.
We might consider a row-based representation.
Where we care about different
fruits having a type, a ripeness
and a price.
How about a cell-based representation,
where Alice's banana data is
used to make a juice with a
size and a freshness.
These diagrams represent how Alice's
banana data might propagate
through a data warehouse,
and the key takeaway here is that data lineage
is difficult,
and just like with real fruit,
it's not always possible to unmix
the sundae.
Now let's say we want to model some user interactions,
where Alice's phone is interacting
with the smoothie, fruit basket
and bread applications.
In this case,
we have set policies
such that Alice's banana data can
be used in the smoothie and the fruit
basket use cases.
But not in the bread application.
To take the analogy full circle,
perhaps we have a policy here that
blocks the usage
because we don't want to heat up bananas.
Which is necessary when baking bread.
For some more details about how
our privacy aware infrastructure works,
check out our security and privacy
blog posts,
um, which show more about how meta enforces
what we call purpose limitation,
uh, via our privacy aware infrastructure
at scale.
Right, to uh to wrap this up,
we will land the plane here with
uh threat detection,
incident response systems,
and close the loop,
These systems close the loop and give us confidence
that our cloud AI environments are well
secured.
We stream VPC flow logs to our
internal systems and run analysis
in real time to detect anomalies.
We stream S3 data events
to monitor what's going on with our S3 buckets,
and we make extensive use of third-party monitoring
applications, including Wiz
and also guard duty for threat detection.
Automation beats out human response
time, and by instrumenting everything
and using a central account
for host detecting, for hosting detection
systems,
we gain the ability to automate
remediation and isolation,
If things go wrong.
With that,
it's back to Robin to wrap things up.
Thank you, Peter.
Yep, so as we wrap up, I
appreciate all you spending the time
in this journey that we've got on today.
If you think you remember we started out this journey
of imagining what
it took to secure those experiences
for those 3.5 billion daily
active users. I think
Peter gave us some amazing insight onto,
you know, meta's real world implementations
and really seeing that
security at scale is more. Than just
more of the same controls,
it's fundamentally rethinking
how security works when you're operating
at that planetary scale,
you know, coming back to the principles
we talked about earlier,
the ability to automate
manual processes inevitably
fail at scale.
Automation isn't optional, and
it's the only way to ensure consistent.
Security enforcement across vast
infrastructure.
I think back you're talking about
their infrastructures cloud deployments,
that automated credential
vending
through AD, and how
that enables both security
and velocity for
their developers,
you know, the proactive
security by design, making sure that
security is not an afterthought.
In your organization and building it
from the ground up,
uh, their AI approach
and policy validation
throughout the CICD pipelines
ensure that those controls are baked in
from the start, um,
when. When you federate and
provide teams with that freedom to
integrate, to innovate
within an organizational
boundary, uh,
through the multi-account strategy
and the use of those service control policies
to establish those guardrails, you again
enable that velocity while managing
the risk and, um,
final two pieces here,
you know. Being able to rely
on your resiliency,
understanding your failure modes, and
designing systems that can detect and recover
from those events, and at scale
it's not if something will fail,
but when.
So Meta's approach to network segmentation
and threat detection enables them
to respond quickly to unanticipated
events.
And all of that wraps up
with a a learning culture,
taking advantage
of these real world experiences
where every event, every incident is
an opportunity to learn and
strengthen
your security posture.
Yeah. So
what I hope that you take away
from today is
Peter shared this staggering scale
that Meta operates at,
and I think early on I called it
just another Wednesday afternoon,
but we all have our Wednesday
afternoons and no matter
what your scale, the fundamentals
of effective cloud security
remain consistent.
Know your critical assets,
implement appropriate controls
and build security into
your processes
from the beginning
so I'd encourage you to ask yourself
which of these principles can
you apply,
where can I use automation to
reduce my risk, and how can
I build a learning culture
around security.
And start with what you can do
today, whether that's implementing
your first service control
policy, adopting infrastructure
as code,
or adding automation
to your existing
security work
workflows.
Working with Meta on
these journeys has taught me
that sailing security isn't just
about protecting more resources,
it's enabling your business to grow
confidently,
knowing that your security posture
is growing with it,
so. So thank you all
for being here with us today.
Thank you, Peter, for sharing Meta's incredible
journey and Syed for going
deep on those some of those AWS
security
um services powering
um at scale deployments.
Please complete the session survey in
your mobile app. Your feedback helps us
keep delivering valuable
content. Enjoy the
rest of Reinvent and do remember
security at scale
starts with the right principles.
So thank you.